and as the cops greetings from podcast
Ville its Wednesday the 8th of [ __ ]
July get your [ __ ] together
take this [ __ ] melee
[Music]
Wednesday you dirty box up the up stay
for some swinging dick day for others
you know I'm saying it's all up to you
you're gonna meet those people it's
Wednesday
go [ __ ] yourself would you rather be an
osmolar ventilate it you're out you're
breathing you LSP be [ __ ] ten I'll
jump up on top I'm trying to put
together a mix here listen I like
smoking joints but not really anymore
really yeah it's just pain he has to
smoke sometimes I went in my collection
I pulled up a little [ __ ] meal pipe I
soaked an eyeball all day that's how I
rolled to get their speed those models
out of there at the same time I soaked
the [ __ ] head of the bar nice nice
soap that I cleaned out I clean my bong
every three days without ball
I got a scrubber I don't want no bad
spirits in there thing looks tip-top
Magoo like it's [ __ ] Brando but
anyway yeah I told you [ __ ] it
the one I do drop by with some [ __ ]
hash look at these [ __ ] thing oh and
it comes in this little glass tank
listen to it ooh listen to this watch
this oh so on Wednesday today I decided
we're gonna smoke a little [ __ ] Hashi
and I got two types ash I got this one
from the one-eyed Jew and I got this
other black slab hash that my buddy gave
me to have to calm this so I've had this
for a couple months I just been saving
it you know I'm saying
sometimes you gotta save [ __ ] you just
can't run home and smoke like a jerk
ball you gotta save it for a special
occasion look at this I just ate a piece
before long yeah we - no read some of
Bruce Lee's stuff you haven't eaten
money you don't even expect from me but
anyway I don't give a [ __ ] what he
thinks it's Wednesday we got to get down
there's the [ __ ] church all
right the Holy Smoke has to blow big -
these [ __ ] microphone
there's people are down people don't
know what to do but Uncle Joe is here
you know I'm saying to turn that frown
upside down [ __ ] you [ __ ]
slinging dick and giving out bubble gum
I don't give a [ __ ] what you got spark
up a bowl a joint I don't care if you
light your [ __ ] finger on fire
you got a firecracker thrown at grandma
I got no time becomes an even throw
firecrackers you grab my little motto
react if I had a grand might throw it at
it but you know just to see them running
[ __ ] grandma I used to have a grandma
you know George's mother was my George's
grandmother was my grandma and when I
lived with them she got a phone inside
her room and I would wait till she was
watching let him and she loved Dave let
him she was Panamanian and she loved
Dave Letterman she's going there at
night and I wait till she'd watch
Letterman like gone to the kitchen the
phone pick it up and this is way before
caller ID be by 11:30 corley 12 and I
call and you could hear her in the room
going who the [ __ ] is calling me at the
11:45 do three times a night for about
[ __ ] three months and then and then I
started doing it at night and then
listen the best one I would leave the
house at 7:00 and when I get to the
corner I would call her again at about
7:30 and hit it with her and she would
[ __ ] hang up the phone I come home
for dinner she be like somebody keep
calling the [ __ ] house making [ __ ]
noises I'm gonna find the who he's
[ __ ] is and I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
him you understand me call my grandma
you know there's a lot of crazy people
out there you got a deal with it sure
enough she goes in the bedroom she gets
her slippers on she pulls her teeth that
I hit her with a [ __ ] Wow click this
one on I even moved to [ __ ] Colorado
and would do it to her right and I come
back and she's like a new [ __ ] belief
that somebody still calling my phone and
go I go grandma's Wow
she goes you saw them on [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey Jana Wednesday that's not it clean
the [ __ ] spirits out you know I'm
saying if you got listen refocus Corona
[ __ ] let's go on a limb with Brendon
shop here we cook us corona he smoke
reefer
it clogs up the receptors for the
Corolla can't hate you I think you might
as well start smoking cigarettes too why
you're a time letting up pills backwards
I don't know I don't [ __ ] on
different listen there's so much
information but anyway this podcast and
ibaka wrong it's about us it's [ __ ]
Wednesday [ __ ] nothing new has
happened uh my daughter turns seven and
a half today one thing that did bother
me I just saw something very disturbing
and we need to address this right now on
the church you know man
I've been on an uphill battle with
[ __ ] weight and getting healthy since
2007 let's a quick blow a couple months
later I saw it I thought about the
damage I had done to my body I'd seen it
when I lived in Colorado once I saw I
told you home with bloody mind to like
an alcohol class you've got a bunch of
duis before duis or duis they call them
something else and they showed the
effects of alcohol on the body and I
never forgot that like when you drink it
affects you deliver dis dis dis your
mind and I just remembered and I thought
about the Tony he is a cocaine well I
did and I just said I gotta fix all
these things you know I gotta fix the
dopamine levels in my mind you know
there were so many things I went to some
doctors and talked to them and I was
very honest and very frank but that that
has been my mission you know pretty much
now I know real rome was never built on
the day nothing's ever built in the day
so you have to look at yourself
objectively and go you know I want to do
these things this is how I'm gonna do
them and this is how I'm gonna stick to
it it's very rare I mean it's to the
point now where it's very rare I even
touch of soda like there is
I don't want the baby how long my
daughter growing up with soda naps so
we've been keeping the soda in the
freezer if somebody wants to Seoul to go
out to the garage and get it
in fact we split so there's me and my
wife even if they diet
like I just every week I've been trying
to do better over this quarantine I gave
a bacon I'm not a [ __ ] Muslim I'm not
you know I got no religious asylum with
anybody on my Jewish I just thought that
two slices of bacon is 14 slices a week
you know we can loan them now and you
gotta take care of a few things and you
know what guess what guys for all the
[ __ ] I talked to you guys about
that's what I'm doing now I mean egg
whites
I'm not eating egg whites by themselves
bite your [ __ ] tongue I rather have
hummus [ __ ] filled in my eyeballs
I eat scrambled eggs because I know it
takes up long my stomach so I need less
[ __ ] food I was eating two sunny-side
up eggs and just eating a [ __ ] yolk
with a piece of toast and that don't do
none for you you're hungry three hours
later you take three [ __ ] eggs four
eggs and you whip them up with some salt
and pepper and some ketchup on that
[ __ ] what I do guy say watching
you eat just the yolk is pretty
impressive it's a thing to see yeah I
[ __ ] cut around it like Paulie in
Goodfellas with the garlic I bring my
own razor blade I don't touch the
[ __ ] white I [ __ ] hate the white
the taste of it as a kid I don't know
what I hate more the white or the
[ __ ] milk anything white like that I
[ __ ] can't stand don't get me started
so sorry I [ __ ] have been whipping it
up eggs and and so I saved on two points
I get two points so I get seven grams of
protein per eggs so I get 28 for
breakfast a piece of toast is two points
and butter is one point I just give it
like a little [ __ ] Puerto Rican
spread on half the piece I don't have to
be butter on the whole thing and it
works and if I don't do that I throw
down oatmeal and that's what I've been
doing over the break if I if I look at
what accomplishments I made that's it I
wish I got a road of [ __ ] ballet or I
could've rode Tommy I could
tanja pounds I did gain some weight the
first month and a half because of the
cortisol levels but I'm back down to my
fighting weight so I'm happy about that
I'm banging out as a bicycle but I
didn't I never took [ __ ] when I was
listen when I was 17 I was doing angel
dust I wasn't thinking about being
[ __ ] 57 with a family and a child and
a podcast and doing comedy when I was
twenty five eat another bothers at night
like they were going out of style in
prison I was not thinking about being
[ __ ] 50 okay when I was 38 going on
the road and eating bar food at the road
onion ring was like they were going out
of style I never thought I would get to
50 and then when I was 45 I stopped
doing blow and I'm like I gotta take
care myself a little by little I made
adjustments I went to Weight Watchers
again I started a 4 [ __ ] 18 and I
started peeing in my pants when I was
going to ring for 3 minutes 3 minutes I
would piss my [ __ ] pants now I could
ride my bike for 50 minutes you know
unfuckin stopped and the only reason
when I stopped using my shoulders hurt
from [ __ ] old onto the bike so tight
because I'm [ __ ] flying down the bike
with a [ __ ] red helmet on I'm saying
tonight I saw a church member from day
one in fact he goes back with us to
[ __ ] Beauty and the Beast I don't
know if he wanted to talk about him or
not but he put a picture up so I might
as well talk about him and not in a bad
way I'm using him as you know to give
him light for the church and to give
others for the church Sergio Tate is a
good man comes to 90% of my shows
whether I'm in [ __ ] Oakland San Jose
San Francisco the punchline and Cobbs
I mean Sergio tango first came into my
life on Beauty and the Beast he sent an
email about [ __ ] in an ambulance or
some [ __ ] like that they didn't catch
him or something like that I'm like
that's absurd and he [ __ ] stuck to
his guns he's like [ __ ] you you fat [ __ ]
I'm telling you I [ __ ] my wife an
ambulance
I had to believe him he's fighting for
it so excuse me we think I hit off this
ash I'm gonna roll here so he's a good
man he's one of us
he's family and whatever he reaches out
you know I reach out to him he comes
down he brings his beautiful [ __ ]
family he's got a beautiful wife
well let's cut the chase tonight he puts
up a [ __ ] picture of his foot with a
bandage which what looks like a toe
missing and he said don't let diabetes
or a bob and I mean I can't I gotta be
honest to you guys I know Sergio you
know as well as I know anybody else and
if a tear came down my like I started
feeling it for him
he's got children so I want the church
to say a prayer if you know Serge Ortega
on Facebook reach out to him touch based
on because that's what we do that's what
we do here on the church we reach out to
the wounded ones then they're not
looking for twenty bucks they're not
looking for [ __ ] you to take him to
lunch
they're not looking for that like that
all they're looking for is to let you
know that the church always has your
back just let them know whatever he
needs if you're in the area I mean
there's some great people up in that Bay
Area you know I'm sure you know Sergio
from shows and stuff like that I don't
even know if I should be given giving me
giving up this information I'm sorry if
I am but he put a picture of his foot up
on whatever and some people were talking
about glucose levels and whatever listen
I got fears I'm not scared of dying
we're all gonna [ __ ] die we all have
a [ __ ] expiration date one man knows
it every day [ __ ] reaches in a
canister and he picks out a [ __ ] name
and I'm saying or he picks up three
names and he lets Jesus picking on some
Chinese guy that's walking by I don't
[ __ ] know you know we don't we don't
have an exploration I don't know we all
have an expiration date but what I'm
trying to tell you [ __ ] savages is
that just trial
a little bit you know I mean yeah maybe
a little bit to me tonight my wife made
all these steaks and maybe I hit a piece
of her me play didn't [ __ ] touch the
baked potato I didn't touch the bother
you know like I said I the [ __ ]
edibles I love them
the downside is the [ __ ] hatin I gave
my friend the can of that easy quick
easy and he said that he woke up in the
night and he ate three bags of candy
throw in the garbage
he couldn't stop eating the toffee you
know you know many nights I've been
there allow me but I can't even stop my
hands I'm just chewing before I could
think the stop like I'm just shoving
[ __ ] I wish I was lying to you I wish I
was lying to you you know my wife found
an apple and the [ __ ] blanket the
other day you need that a [ __ ] Apple
in the blanket I must have fall asleep
eating the [ __ ] Apple in the blanket
that's marijuana that's not heroin
that's not alcohol I don't drink I don't
do dick that's five 420 milligrams
whatever we did I get fired at night at
least you had an apple
I had an apple a protein shake that's
crazy
first I always have an apple that's a
rule if you're not hungry enough for an
apple you ain't hungry so I cut my wife
buy apples I'll just give you that rule
when you're high low know that it works
and the Apple takes a lot of space in
your stomach yeah
so you pop one Apple then you're a
little hungry
you pop a second app nothing wrong with
that guarantee you're gonna [ __ ]
tomorrow remember what's the old saying
an apple a day keeps the doctor away
save that app before it night so you
wake up in the morning and the ship
flies out of your ass like a torpedo
there's no drama there's no pushing
there's no reading the newspaper you
just sit and the hell poop the submarine
flies out you [ __ ] put the bidet on
your wipe a little bit and you're off
and [ __ ] running so I pop the two
apples I'm a little hungry I can make a
protein shake with three ice cubes and
water and two scoops you know it's not
bad it's dirty grandma's a pro
teen I wake up a the money I drink a
coke I'm learning coffee first
did I do a four shot expresso and I wait
for the [ __ ] [ __ ] to just blow up
I pop two garlic pills with the
espressos to give them to give the
[ __ ] room some scent to let the root
to make the paint [ __ ] dry and I go
to work Jack I'm an old man I got
systems here you got to keep that
[ __ ] parish you drop it you know I'm
saying what are you gonna do oh it's
drop it oh you got a drop let me fill
one more bowl up and then we'll get a
little more of a [ __ ] story all right
hello the idea that Jesus takes a turn
picking name somebody taste the [ __ ]
amazing buckets where he goes out there
picks a Jew ah whatever the [ __ ] he
speaks I don't know not even wine when
you [ __ ]
believe me let's smoke a little piece
and we'll talk about it later who the
[ __ ] am I [ __ ] criticize you
[ __ ] what I'm trying to say to
you is do me a favor
right last week Felicia came over the
house Michaels who I love with all my
heart she came over to hang out with my
wife and me we all had masks on we sat
outside but she brought got a bunch of
[ __ ] great stuff and that's my wife I
took a little spoon in the apple pie
that was it I don't try to eat sugar at
night I avoided night like the [ __ ]
plague because that's all I think in my
mind I would become diabetic and my
[ __ ] fat little Cuban stole mine I
think if I eat because one day I went to
the [ __ ] doctor as I was walking in I
looked I lost the cookie in the car it
would look loser cookie in the car who
wants the cookie in the car I couldn't
[ __ ] find it two weeks I'm looking
for this [ __ ] cookie
I put the iPod in the car and I open up
the backseat and there's the [ __ ]
cookie sitting there like half melted
I'm like I'm not gonna let that go to
waste that's a kanji of milligrams so I
ate the cookie before I wanted to the
doctor's office oh I didn't know this
[ __ ] was gonna blast out a drug
test on me oh no no not a drug that's
the blood test
drug that's why is it doctor gonna able
to drug this I didn't know he's gonna
drop a [ __ ] blood test on me try
kosher let me do the blood test [ __ ]
two hours later I got a call in my house
you better get down here what the [ __ ]
do you got in your system what is all
this sugar are you talking about good
you went over the [ __ ] mark like you
[ __ ] white higher than you've ever
been what's going on with you well it's
it's funny thing you mentioned that
night because obviously I'm not anywhere
talk about health but I have noticed
that eating sugar at night like it if I
don't sleep I look back oh I had sugar
at night like that never used to happen
like Shirley Dean what Dean Del Ray has
done has shown me even if you just get
out sugar that's a ton of stuff like
that sugar is I respect Dean Del Ray
more Dean Del Ray inspires the [ __ ] out
of me
I thought him pick something up out of
the garbage for Dean done right today I
was riding my bike this morning and
people are moving so Dean collects old
speakers and [ __ ] like that
some ride my [ __ ] bike I'm on the
other side of [ __ ] Laurel Canyon and
those side streets there and I see
[ __ ] under a tree I see an old school
amplifier oh [ __ ]
with four [ __ ] speakers doesn't just
like you know I led zepplin type
speakers like from the 70s so I call
Dean cuz Dean moved to the valley and he
didn't answer and I went home and I
called Dean again the answer he goes I'm
in Los Feliz it was Dean over to this
place
I had the address I could go over there
I hit a fee in the bushes [ __ ] it I got
off the bike about the amplifier for him
and other things and then I went back
people were outside like [ __ ] walking
their dogs and I put the hamper fire in
the back of the Subaru oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
justice cuz I know Dean knows what these
people are very good at that not me I'm
not good at fixing [ __ ] there's people
who look at something open the back
put a [ __ ] wire and it's brand new
and surface it repaint it clean it up
and they go on eBay
til Dean does that all day long I ain't
mad at you you're hustling yeah I got
another friend Damon he's on eBay all
day those are my golf clubs and [ __ ] you
know yeah
listen there's just people you got to do
what you got to do but speaking of
speakers and speaking of amplifiers we
zoomed this weekend because of the
coronavirus numbers spiking again so I
didn't want to bring him in but I want
to introduce my brother he came in for
his trial ejected to talk about music
touring out what he's doing in his spare
time and what he's doing to [ __ ]
battle the quarantine blues bring in
Rudy Sarzo we want to welcome a brother
to the podcast my main man my cuban
patriot my political prisoner of love
mr. Rudy Sarzo get bossa Coco Gabe I
said I want you buddy so you play I'm
into the gym since February yeah because
you know we've been on tour prior to
that and then the last show we did was
Epcot Center in Orlando they they
there's like an amphitheater there and
it's you know it's seasonal eggs like
every day there's a band playing you
know and we were supposed to be there
for like three days but we were gonna
leave on Friday and to say they you know
the Cole management and say listen we're
gonna need you guys to finish off on
Sunday because we're gonna shut the park
down on Sunday and instead of bringing
in a band that comes comes it on
Saturday and only play for half of the
engagement will rather extend you guys's
engagement and we went from like a pact
on Thursday yeah on Tuesday do you say
Thursday when we first started packed
house not in a single seat open I got
photos to the last show we did there
were like five people so I lent it out
of that quick like the word yeah oh yeah
oh yeah I I took photos yeah let's say
shut down on Sunday Sunday night I would
say by by Friday you could see a trickle
people just not showing up and so you've
been home since March 15 March 15 yeah I
saw more people at the airport than it
did at the yeah yeah and how is the
quarantine how you handled it well so
far since March I don't have any whole
thing at the quarantine
you know being a musician I I'm used to
isolation even if I'm in my hotel room I
got my bass with me
and I'm I'm on YouTube and I'm learning
and I'm expanding my my my musical back
you know vocabulary and just you know
being creative I do the same thing at
home so it's like another day for you
it's just like I know the day yeah I be
you know eight when you turn on the news
it's horrific to hear about it's
horrific so that's not another day
that's something else but you know just
once in a while turn it off and get
within myself find some peace personally
because I was getting really angry I got
I gotta tell you about a month and a
half ago it all started you know with we
start out in lockdown right we're locked
down and I see messages on TV
advertisement you know we're all in this
together we're a kinder people and
kumbaya we're gonna be much better
humanity after this immediately like
like six to eight weeks later BAM
everything goes to [ __ ] that's rioting
there's looting and I'm thinking
whatever happened you know people just
snapped it just [ __ ] snapped you know
and that guy and it's like a you know
domino effect
it just it's got to a point that reached
me I was flipping out you know then I
realized wait a minute 40 years ago 40
years ago I was sleeping on a floor with
nothing totally destitute no future no
nothing but I was at peace I was a peace
with God the universe whatever people
want to call out I call it God and I was
at peace and this was like
man I gotta get back to that because I
couldn't be any more blessed than I am
and Here I am at war with myself and the
rest of the frickin universe yeah I see
when you find yourself in isolation
yeah quarantine and you have a wife you
have the dogs you have the bass you have
all these things but as human beings we
also have a thing called the mind that's
what we all share and I'll tell you
during this I'd like to do a documentary
and interview people about what their
experience was and how they broke it
down how the levels of your frustration
turned to anger fear you went through
every emotion from April till two weeks
ago you went through every emotion in
the book and it was high alert like that
your anxiety was high a few days that if
you weren't anxious your fear was high
and then you getting all this
information that nobody seems right like
you getting all this information thrown
at you and nothing seems right but I
found myself the second week I was
alienating I was playing with the baby
and talking to them and eating dinner
with them but besides that I was hiding
from them
I just kept hiding from them and one
night I was in my office and I know what
the [ __ ] am i doing I'm at war with
myself my wife is sitting in that living
room all by herself
let me go talk to her tell her what's
going on with me just so she knows I
don't put a [ __ ] gun in my mouth or
something because I would never even
think about something like that but
there were nights during this that your
mind wanders your mind wanders for you
it might have been a night the third
night of the Ozzy Osbourne tour where
you flicked a cigarette and it burnt
something god forbid I could've lit
their auditorium up and now it hits you
now that you could lift the auditorium
up you know stupid [ __ ] like that ya
played with me so when
I made peace with my wife I wanted that
thing and I told her what was on my mind
and what I've been thinking about we
became our level of the relationship
grew a bump it wasn't even about years
now was more about trust I told her
exact you know [ __ ] that when you're a
man you don't want to share with anybody
you know like you're like I'm supposed
to be a man I'm supposed to be the man
of the house
but I still have my my you know you
can't sit chinks in your armor
you know there's nothing wrong with
being a man in the house and having a
few chinks in your arm so I went in the
living room and sat with her and talked
to her and let her know what I was
feeling and told her to keep her eye on
me and everything changed
anxiety levels drop fears dropped the
news you cannot watch unless you're a
glutton for punishment watching the news
as an American is me sitting you down
tying you up and what's that [ __ ] they
battle board you when you're in want
honorable what aborted yeah waterboard
you think about it when you watched the
the 7:00 a.m. to the three o'clock news
din the World News Tonight your anxiety
levels go up right up as you're sitting
there you got to unwind your legs so I
made a rule I was like Terry no more TV
in the daytime so usually she puts the
TV on just a clean and walk around and I
would be in my office and I could hear
Corona
Chase is growing I'm trying to write
something I'm trying to focus on
something and once you hear Corolla
that's right so listen the TV can't go
on until 5:00 then we pushed it to 6:00
so now the TV doesn't go on until 6:00
if the baby wants to watch TV I have to
camp you go on a [ __ ] room and watch
Disney - but there's no TV I don't want
her hearing you know there was a couple
of nights where in the living room
building Legos the TV's on the family
room and you can hear the TV like 80
people died today
I don't it goes even though she doesn't
react to it it goes into here and then
turn a psyche the first three weeks of
March she didn't want to go out bro
she didn't want to go out just from what
she had heard on the news not from us
because I don't put fear and uh that's I
was watching her
as a seven-year-old girl how she wrapped
her head around this and I started
looking at it and then I started forcing
to go out I go as long as we have our
mask on we can [ __ ] go out we started
going out and we started riding bicycles
then I got a bicycle from the neighbor
and little by little we took baby steps
you know was just baby steps and now I'm
okay I'm not ready to hit an airport I'm
not ready to get on a bus or a shuttle
with eight or nine people I'll tell you
that much
I'm not ready for all that [ __ ] I'm
ready like even with you you live ops
skip and a jump and I was a Rudy let's
not even do it
this is gonna be a bad week right here
this is a bad week it's in the air you
know so I'm happy we got to at least see
each other yes usually we do our monthly
over Anna
yeah the Cuban joint but I went by there
yesterday
the Cuban joint don't even have tables
outside yet oh no no you have to call
order and take it in the box don't even
want to put Burbank is putting tables
out there like this starting to put
tables out there but any day now the
other side cuz people never satisfy
because they're doing in New York do if
you go to New York now they're putting
the tables out and they put barricades
on the street so people could eat like
if it's a lot of restaurants and Red
Bank New Jersey and places like that
you're gonna get the people I'm I got a
handicap chair I can't go through
I can't walk through so there's always
gonna be somebody that [ __ ] any day
now within an hour bet you five American
dollars within a week somebody's gonna
raise their hands and say the
Disabilities Act is gonna sue New York
City cuz they can't get through with
that one leg whatever the [ __ ] it is
this always somebody who's unhappy with
something now you cannot say social
media has become social media was fun
it's not even fun no more when you go on
social media it's like you go on a fight
he
if you write something positive they
turn it into something negative but I'm
not mad at them Rudy they've been locked
in a house they've been lied to
they're broke their taxes are due in 10
days and unemployment runs out on July
31st how would you feel right now as an
American you didn't get your stimulus
check your president doesn't want a mask
this guy tells you that it's airborne
this guy tells you that you can't get it
from sucking [ __ ] this guy you know I'm
saying so every day there's no info
thrown that year so this is what I've
done I did the same thing you did you
know what I don't need to listen to
anything I will wear my mask I will not
go out anywhere where there's more than
six or seven people jerking off in the
circle and I'll stand on my family and
I'll trace my steps everywhere I go is
very simple I mama I live in my own
little prison I'm like no I'm like
what's his name what Pablo will like
Pablo Francisco
Escobar you picked your own [ __ ]
prison Whole Foods the gym the weed
store and the [ __ ] of the house I have a
furlough two times a day I leave for an
hour I go to the weed store I get a
little Nova Thor cryotherapy I still
have not gotten the nerve to go into the
freezer yet I could do the Nova Thor the
red light therapy where you lay down for
20 minutes and the lights hit you but I
still haven't had the balls to go into
the freezer yet that's how I'm
wishy-washy at 8:00 I'll admit it we all
have fears or something you know yeah
you just mentioned something before
about you know looking at everybody else
and just my reaction is everybody has a
journey everybody has a destiny and
can't keep people from doing things it's
part of what their trip is gonna be you
know mine is to not be affected
negatively by it to a certain degree you
know just let it go it's like when when
you and I when we were in our 20s I'm
gonna be 70 years old this year so let's
say looking at somebody 50 years older
than me you know it's like yeah dude you
know it's not your world anymore
it's us we're the new generation the new
generation well I'm part of that now I
have to look at younger generation even
the 20s or the 30s who are in control
who are creating who are doing things
who were influencing and say you know
whether I like it or not it's their
world 15 years from now they'll go
through the same thing but it's all part
of our journey
you know I'm closer to the end of my
journey that I am at the beginning right
now but my focus is is to like I
mentioned to be at peace because that
was a gift to receive that peacefulness
even up my worst lowest moment in my
life when I was about to turn 30 years
old 30 now I'm about to turn 70 and man
I gotta tell you I was so off track from
that peace of mind that it took this
what has been going on for the last
census you know since March or whatever
- actually it was like hitting that wall
like you're driving down the freeway and
you [ __ ] hit a wall you go you either
got a crush a bird or you're gonna
survive it what I did is I survived I
came out of that crash and I said holy
[ __ ] and the full realization of what I
have to do is what I'm going through
right now you know what should they look
like now Rudy you know if you're gonna
get to the finer details I won't get out
of bed until I do my my being grateful
meditation gratefulness I play with the
little dog in bed say a prayer and then
I hit the floor run
start making you know making breakfast
I'll watch two or three channels of news
for five minutes world news and local
news immediately going to YouTube and
start searching music tutorials it could
be very variety of subjects and then by
10 o clock my wife gets up and I just
start doing things you know keep it busy
used to this I'm so looking forward to
our podcast today doing a radio show oh
yeah
yeah I do that yeah yeah I make a list
yeah we got a fool at any given
broadcast that we do because you you
can't download it because it's it's a
music centric channel and like if you
have like delivery of podcasts it's cost
prohibitive to include music which is
what we do is conversation and then we
play a lot of music having to do with
the conversation or the special guests
like you you know and and but since we
have music in it we cannot make it
available as a podcast because it's the
publishing laws right we have to pay for
that
yeah so you only play it to one time one
time well it's it then we have two or
three broadcasts
you know play play now maybe a couple of
months later and then through through
the year every every couple of months
now you know I've been doing comedy 29
years obviously I went to see you in 81
or 82 that's 38 years ago how are you
handling with not going out at night how
you handling not going to rehearsal once
a week are you handling not getting
playing on Thursday how are you handling
all those things yeah that's that stuff
because I can't recreate that at home I
mean the act of playing experiencing you
know the whole musical process of being
creative or actually playing a song that
it's part of the set that is just
basically recreating rather than
creating they all have their challenges
so at home as far as playing go Zach I
complete I can play more at home
because when I travel I'm traveling so I
can't play because I'm on a plane or I'm
in a vehicle so I as far as playing
being satisfied for playing yes
performing that's something completely
different because it's that's when you
need people in the audience I did a a
livestream about a month ago with Steel
Panther and yeah that was awesome and it
was very controlled in a in a studio
that was set up not for a for live
streaming but not for what we're going
through right now so it you know it's
been there it's they got all the kinks
out and everything ran incredibly smooth
I played a couple of songs with the guys
and there were about 10,000 people
tuning in live
that's a mate well you know I could see
going deep into the valley getting a
warehouse one of those things like an
airplane hangar and opening up the doors
and if it's five guys you could rehearse
with masks on except for the singer
obviously yeah and everybody's more than
social distance you could stand ten feet
from me and play the [ __ ] Bay yeah
you know yeah I mean that's the only
good thing that musicians do have as
long as there's fresh air coming in
you're not gonna go into a studio shut
the door come on they're alive that's
not gonna happen with some guys sounding
music in the room those days are done
with her right now with eight guys in a
room but that's what you have the
advantage over us I mean yeah you go
back on the truck and get a bunch of
people to part on one make believe you
got a social distance but my big problem
is really I don't want anybody to get it
while they're doing business with me I
think that's bad business whether I'm a
comic or as a human being I don't want
to give it I don't want somebody to say
I came on the podcast and got it I want
to want to Joey Diaz his shows and got
it that would bother me to no end that
would bother me
- no [ __ ] end so for that reason is
why I'm not performing you know I I drag
a take the time off like you I've been
doing this for a long time do I miss it
[ __ ] yeah I miss it what do I want to go
up one time and then that go up for
another month
no I don't when I go I want to go I want
to be able to go tomorrow night
and that joke worked and me cry this
Thursday night and that joke worked let
me try that Friday night I don't want to
just do it and then them shut us down
for another month
that's what I'm at once I go for it it's
gonna be my last run I'm gonna be 60 in
two he is this is my last run so I'd
rather stay off now let them get
everything done the temperature checks
that the mom'll in the ass then when you
would kid really they stuck up the
mom'll in yes they don't do that no more
right remember well when I was a kid in
Cuba yeah I mean there was a lot of
stuff I don't know if it's because it
was the 50s and this was going on
everywhere including Cuba and the United
States and whatever but you know if if
if I will catch a cold
my parents my mom will give me an enema
right
that was like part of the Cure to get
the toxins out of your body
aka maybe something that you [ __ ] blood
for [ __ ] today and you were fine I
don't know what it was for not milk of
magnesia I still my mother making me
drink a gallon of prune juice that's
where you [ __ ] all over the walls
humans don't give a [ __ ] jack if they
look on the eyelids and the bloody right
on the eyelids you got problems they
make a steak with eggs right on the spot
they throw away your [ __ ] chicken
nuggets and fruit they just throw it
away my mom made all that [ __ ]
sometimes I see what my wife cooks for
my daughter and I sit down I go my wife
is lucky my mom ain't here
because she would take that dish and
break it over a [ __ ] head
why does my kid have grapes on a dish
like Julius Caesar you know humans don't
play that [ __ ]
they want to see meat potatoes and
vegetable [ __ ] the grapes and the
[ __ ] the other day I told I don't put
nachos on a [ __ ] dish no more white
chips like those Doritos that's not
[ __ ] dinner yeah but she likes I
don't give a [ __ ] what she likes
I like you know I like jumping off
planes you don't see me [ __ ] doing it
you know the [ __ ] is wrong with people
have you been to the Cuban restaurant I
think it's missing one of the terminals
at Atlanta Airport no I have not there's
a Cuban restaurant yes but it's very
Georgia style so it's like even though
it's supposed to be a Cuban restaurant
yes is one of those I think it's F or J
you know it's like really way off you
know you gotta you know you gotta spend
like half an hour in that tram to get
back to Union City you know that I'm
gonna walk through an airport for five
great Cuban food this style is
nato-georgia in Cuba this way peanut
that wheel which is what you did yeah
when you go to like a greata OB Chaya at
the Miami International Airport oh my
god you can't miss what you see here's
the thing you can't get a good flight
from LAX to Miami
so you just travel recently you gotta
fly into for a lot yeah yeah they got
weird flights oh yeah JetBlue flights
into West Palm Beach you could take mint
and and drive the hour into Miami ofor a
lot of del flies into more detail yeah
so that sucks but I I can't tell you how
many times I woke up all over like a
[ __ ] in Miami you go to the
airport and it's great it really shows
you the class that you look at the keel
you look at the Cuban coffee place and
there's a line out the ass yeah look at
Starbucks and this one guy work he yells
his own orders like let me gonna Mecca
Chino
he runs over makes it because you got to
be an [ __ ] in Miami to pay 450 for a
coffee when you got Cubans giving you a
[ __ ] they give you that cellophane
cup cuz you get one shot for like 50
cents well you like fluff it let me the
six shot up dollars and you pour some
sugar and that [ __ ] you get on a
plane like [ __ ] who's the god Michael
Jackson like Peter Pan that's what you
look like when you get on a panting
you're spinning around and [ __ ] people
looking at it you're singing you're
whistling and then you take the Cuban
sandwiches but you don't have them cook
them you say let me get ten Cuban
sandwiches just don't cook them and
they'll look at you weird you like mind
your business just do what I tell you
put the Cuban sandwiches in the bag it's
like you're holding them up they can't
understand it I gave the sandwich I put
them right over me and then you get home
then you put them in the oven and you
cook them up that's all they're gonna do
but if they cook them by the time you
bring them home they're like a [ __ ]
brick so I when I go to Miami on the way
out I am excited as a liking for the
flight leaves at 7:00 I got the flight
leaves at 8:00 and I got a beer 7:00 I
get that six because I get there and I
have a seven course meal for breakfast I
won't get up with six and purposely
smoked two joints when I leave Miami
because I know at the airport thing I
mean no eggs those powdered eggs with
those [ __ ] cat sausages and some they
always give me the wrong bread not on
mmmmmm and then that and I go in there
and do you know that they serve
heavy-duty [ __ ] in the morning like most
places when only serve breakfast till
11:00 not Cuban people you could go in
there at 8:00 and say let me get number
25 god nickel bappa with red beans in
fried bananas and there's a guy back
that's dying to make those he was just
thinking about them themselves
he was in the mood for eggs either I
will get on a [ __ ] I will sit there
and get the carne con Papa's
with an extra order of Platanos and
right
some beans give me extra rice and I will
kill that whole dish that's the only one
I can fly into Miami because then I
won't even take my mask off on the plane
you get so [ __ ] filled in Miami then
you got the 15 Cubans hanging over you
and there's a little oven in the plane
you tell that you give that stewardess a
5-hour bill and tell that [ __ ] to heat
it up and you get yourself a Cuban
sandwich everybody else is eating that
[ __ ] they eat on a plane that moosh
they give you [ __ ] that I love that
Miami International and you just don't
throw out there enough yeah yeah usually
see what I do is I go from LA to Miami I
take a red-eye direct from LAX to Miami
and then I go see my mom that's right
good one yeah
so I'm there like you know like three
four you know four or five days and then
IIIi schedule it so from Miami I fly to
the next the guess-who gig because most
of our gigs are on the East Coast so I
have to go to Atlanta anyways to me you
know to get to like Boise let's say you
know whatever you know like not the
major hubs because I could always fly
Miami to Chicago but that's not where
I'm going so I have to go through
Atlanta to get to my final destination
and that's when you hit the [ __ ] cube
enjoy yes that's what I sit there and
yeah Papa rellena that's my favorite
it's got everything he's got the carbs
and it's got the protein you know one
shot meal there's no frying so you get
the cholesterol level up my [ __ ]
favorite Apple for food is north
Newark's got a crab cake place that's
like nationally known and at 6:00 in the
morning you're gonna get two crab cakes
and two eggs sunny-side up Wow with
toast and little potatoes let me tell
you something we listen to me the first
time I went in there I only ate one
because I was trying to stick to my
weight watcher points I got no reason
alive nobody at home I would stab myself
on the neck when I was standing on that
plane for not again
more than swapping things that's how
good they are
Philips lookup Philips [ __ ] crabcakes
it's like internationally-known they're
like Run DMC on the microphone I get
stupid I rain that rages stay away from
me if it contagious whatever the [ __ ]
oh they're frozen ones they got bigger
melon to you phenomenal at that airport
you get two crab cakes and two eggs
sunny-side up with toast hold the bacon
I don't even need the bacon why are we
throwing bacon in there what what am i
what is my name [ __ ] Phil get the
[ __ ] outta here you saying what I was
Rudy how are you dealing with the no
touring I mean cuz let me tell you what
happens when you tour for people who
don't know this at home my wife and I
are very much in love I love my wife
very much but let me tell you so
guess who likes me going on the road the
most my wife because in 29 years in 20
years we've been together
she's been used to me leaving twice a
month
so those are two nights she could sit on
the couch and scratch your ass and smile
her fingers and watch The Walking Dead
no English shows and nobody gives a [ __ ]
I'm saying cuz I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna sit there watch those [ __ ]
shows she watches so that's the night
I'm saying like it's like last night I
went out we just did a late night
podcast you know and this morning she
told me when I woke up the next day she
was like that was kind of nice last and
I didn't take it personal cuz I know
they're both used to it
they've been used to it so this doesn't
even affect us only it affects our wives
the people around this house your wife
taken it I mean she must be happy that
you're home
yeah she's happy we should make a joke
you know before things are the way they
are now it's like if I will be home for
like three weeks and you know I don't
make jokes about okay you know she'll
say something I said okay that's alright
don't worry I'm leaving in a couple of
days you know
uh but having said that you know we just
celebrate our 36 wedding anniversary a
couple of weeks ago and we've been
together since 81 and I you know we're
in a really really good place in our
marriage
all around and I'm glad that it went in
that direction because it could have
gone the opposite aeration right now we
could be filing for divorce you know but
there's certain things like you know you
either do one thing or you embrace that
thing and it is to embrace our
relationship and and also our
relationship with ourselves just going
back to being at peace with yourself you
know because I could be a piece with any
anything outside of me without being a
peace with myself you know what I mean
nonsense you know
yeah sky you know being a peace with
with my family my wife or you know my
brother my mom you know it's like it's
really gonna be a peace with myself and
then I said okay now I can if I did
anything wrong okay I'm at peace with
that you know if I did I say if I say
something wrong to my mom the other day
or whatever you know and it's like okay
I did so apologize and you be a peace
with yourself I see yourself and
apologize to your mom you know it's just
an example and so you know going back to
the 40 years ago you know having that
feeling that sense of peace it was like
an epiphany it was like a a it a
revelation to me you know it just hit me
and I became that person from that point
on and I'm talking about being on the
floor destitute couple of days later I
get the phone call from Ozzie from
Sharon Ozzie the next day that triggered
the rest of my life the journey just it
was a change you know and I've been
accumulating a lot of [ __ ] stuff
material stuff you know I made a lot of
money so you do certain things you buy a
lot of
and you know I I got a house full of
[ __ ] you know full of stuff and I
remember during the 80s it was kind of
like okay you know you go on a big tour
you you buy it you buy a new house and
then you go back on tour so you can pay
for that house it was like it was nuts
you know so it seems like if the focus
became without me realizing it that I
was away that I was not focusing on
peace anymore I was focusing on
happiness the pursuit of happiness
and I gotta tell you it's never ending
because if you're not a peace with
yourself you're never gonna really be
completely happy and there's always
gonna be something else that you want
and something else are you going to
sacrifice that's where there is you know
that's the truth it's so weird that I've
said this on the podcast as day one will
testify to this that this will be the
first time people really looked inside
themselves since maybe high school your
life has been in such a rush since the
summer before College you you got this
that and you bought it you bought it
your counselors you shouldn't be an
editor you should be a director switch
majors and then you get out and then you
gotta find a job then you get a job and
there's an apartment and and then never
end and you meet a girl and you get
married it and one day you actually it's
like that it's like that David Byrne
song you know how did I get here that's
right you know and that's what happened
to me during this breakdown that it was
like how the [ __ ] did I get here so I
started breaking into ten year period
it's like how much has happened the last
ten years a family a wife a kid touring
you know writing dealing with people and
then the ten years before that it was
surviving getting off the drugs you know
was always a struggle so now I'm a piece
of myself you know the last two weeks
the nights have started to bother me
like I accepted it for a while yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but now the last two
weeks
nights are starting to bother me I dread
the night because I'm not going anywhere
it's bad enough I didn't go no we're all
dead took a ride I went to the gym I
went for a bike ride I took the baby the
kickboxing you know I drove with a camp
but then the night time comes and I got
nothing to do what do you do you write
calmly you tell jokes to your [ __ ]
mirror you know so my wife goes to bed
at 9:15 you know my wife is up in six
she does pay for cleans the house cooks
the baby we help out I mean she can only
take so much you know so it's I'm
sitting there at night all alone and
sometimes you sit you make notes you
write I'm trying to outline a book you
know but the focus isn't even there to
write
the focus is named Ned outline it's
piece by piece and I gotta put it away I
can't even go there right now you know
so everything else has been at peace
with me all that stuff it's just a
comedy I don't care about the money part
of it either just the ability that I
could go out and tell jokes um where do
I need 200 people yeah I just need eight
people just to get what I'm saying and
get the [ __ ] out of there so that's the
only piece I have everything else I'm at
peace with I know what I want to do I
know I have a plan
for the next 18 months I have a plan I
know what I want to do and I know how I
want to do it and that's it you know you
just mentioned something that adds and I
was I'm listening I'm listening and I'm
thinking wow about the differences and
the similarities of what you and I do
you know we're both entertainers right
but there is even though you're you're
like a tennis player you like a singles
player by that I mean is you need that
other person behind the net
all right back listen I could do a zoom
show to the cows come home it would give
me no satisfaction to stand there like a
gun I'm waiting for an arrow but come
through the [ __ ] screen I know if I
turn down my screen I saw some guy with
a microphone I'd do everything in my
power to shoot the missiles off I know
apples we just got a decoded [ __ ] they
got missiles that'll blow you right up I
don't want to see that I don't want to
see that I wouldn't mind saying
Whitesnake at The Wiltern theater with
25 ticket winners spread out five feet
eight feet apart with pay-per-view I
would pay for that because I know
they're getting some type of energy when
they're you know it's interesting you
say that I'm telling you right now
that's the only way it's gonna happen
right now very interest because it does
the amount does the size of the crowd
affect your performance no no I could do
I'm from The Comedy Store when I first
started there I will get twelve O'Clock
spots following Paul Mooney that means
that once he got up 20 people left for
him and I was faced with eight people
and there was a horrible feeling but
then you learn how to head what's the
word adapt adapt you start you you I
remember saying to somebody what the
[ __ ] is this what am i doing my life I'm
waiting here till 1:00 in the morning to
go on stage for eight people he goes
don't do it cancel but to sign up
outside so how many people will sign up
for that same spot late at 1:00 in the
morning
so I started adapting to hate people I
knew that it wasn't about material
material is not gonna work at 180 people
you're a little setup punchline and any
other work you're gonna oh you gonna
open up with that a little bit but then
you have to go into you cuz it's a
people so it's a different type of
stand-up it's eight people it's eight
people so you got to attack them back
off and then be more you your jokes
aren't gonna work at 1:00 in the morning
you know why because they've already
heard all those topics
so those eight people are energy what
yesterday if you look at Chuck these
thread Chuck delay the tremendous thing
on people somebody said to him why don't
you and the prophets of rage do
something and he replied take a look at
this this is LA this was one of the
hardest audiences I have performed in
front of look at it on YouTube on
YouTube on the stream this would just
look like a regular night to you for us
it was one of the biggest nights of our
lives and it doesn't come through that's
why I don't want to stream a live
concert right now but I think if we
really wanted to entertain people with
all the bands that live in LA we could
contact Live Nation and say look go on
wne whatever the [ __ ] station is
raffle off 25 tickets nobody's making
money there isn't money there's money on
the pay-per-view so you could pay the
seeder off and still the musicians get a
little bit of money
not much Colvin means pay cut in Latin
go to your Latin Cove it means pay cut
in Latin this is a pay cut but I'd
rather take a pay cut and do something
three times a week that I love did not
make any money and sit at home missing
what I love but the clubs won't do that
because there's no money in it for them
it doesn't pay for them to put a people
that's what they made their money for it
from alcohol they make their money from
alcohol so this is the problem we're
running into you know we all know that
Cove a [ __ ] moves quickly I feel in
my world
anything over eight to ten people you
got a problem if they're in a close
proximity and extended longevity you
could bump into Cove it and walk away
from it whatever it's when you're gonna
love train and it
circulating in the air and you're going
from Long Island to the Manhattan and
you're breathing that out for a [ __ ]
hour you know a plane right to Miami
that's five hours some [ __ ] got
cold in there you're breathing that
plane that's what gives you the vid is
the longevity in that situation you know
they're talking about offices now how is
it gonna work with men n95 masks on in
office for eight hours right they're
gonna cut in the workday and cut in the
weekday making three-day weekends well I
don't work for you Lee we still work
seven days a week [ __ ] well I was asked
to you guys are talking about like now
what do you got it went Lee let's say
covert is over this time let's say we're
talking July see whatever next year is
it is it is it even reasonable to ask
you guys to travel anymore is it
reasonable to ask like do you think this
is gonna turn into a different way of
having live events do you think
somebody's gonna change or we're just
waiting for it to go away and then go
back to the way like look could you
booty when you go out and be on a plane
every weekend again like even when this
is over or do you think Oh like now you
realize you don't have to yeah we're
just be weekend's I mean what we do is
that market it's more of the classic
rock it's not the the the bands from the
80s you know I I'm in a band that first
came out of the 60s there were the
platters and you know and the adventures
and all those bands you know the band
because who had the first hit in 1965
you know so it's it's is that audience
you know that comes to see us you know a
lot of casinos we've done a couple of
ships you know which I don't see a rule
book for for next year to be on a couple
of ships again and I don't know but it
all depends if there's a vaccine
available in the very near future
your news about that I hear rumblings of
like there testing going all right
testing now do you want to be one of the
first people I guess that vaccine you
know I am not even one of the first
people that go back to the gym because I
can't really say you know I know once
the FDA approves it unless there's some
malicious intent so like let's say let's
speed up the the process for whatever
reason no it has to go through through
the through the proper channels
you know enough testing okay and they
get some proof to the next level and
next level then you know when we're at
the level that is human it's humanly
safe yeah I'll take it
I'm being optimistic I'm going for next
April I think my next spring will be
okay
I think if same format same everything I
change at all no there's going to be
changes there's definitely gonna be
changes and by that time everybody if
they're not opening up Broadway till
January by the way uh rest in peace Nick
Cordero that was a shame that poor kid
he lost his [ __ ] leg you know awful
Colvin you know an actor on Broadway but
they close and Broadway till January so
that means they open up January first
they're gonna start rehearsing look
what's going on with the sport leagues
already they're already having problems
in those bubbles in those training
facilities it's too many people put
together I think once you put 20 people
in there you really got a problem they
want to play football like some 11 guys
on each side that's 22 guys on the field
at one time plus the three or four
zebras you know that's that's a lot of
contact for Downs baseball's a little
bit more spread out but you still got
people in the dugout baseball might work
you know I'm hoping it all works I want
the country to go back to work but I
don't want to
a hundred thousand people dying you know
me and Lee were joking around the Earth
Day and it's a joke but it's very sad
that after this somebody's gonna do the
FaceTime Chronicles they're gonna do a
whole movie about people dying on
FaceTime you know throwing up gang
signals as they're dying like you know
how many people died on Facebook in
front of their children this year how
many loved ones can we we can't do this
so that's what I'm looking at first off
I don't trust the promoters or their
locations either they have to switch it
up I'm sorry you gotta lose some money
I'm [ __ ] sorry you gotta have one
person to deal with us right when you go
to a casino how many people come in to
talk to you while you're in the back oh
yeah ten people the chief is cousin the
horse trainer the entertainment director
yes the way it is you know all that
needs to get cut down to one every club
has to have a covert agent so as soon as
you walk in the greenroom they take your
temperature
they take their own temperature special
security to walk out to the stage
there's no more headshots there's no
more greet meet and greets if you're
selling merch I don't know what you're
gonna do you're gonna have to have
somebody out there selling the merch for
you with ten mask on and you know
there's just so many things I mean let's
be honest I'm excited I'm going to see
my brother Rudy play I'm [ __ ] psyched
yes I'm smoking dope I got some [ __ ]
edibles he Rudy got me special tickets
third row Orchestra I go I sit down the
opening act comes on Bubba and his five
[ __ ] fat brothers they do a harmonica
they do four songs they get off I will
wait for Rudy and whoever the [ __ ] that
is the guns the [ __ ] Whitesnake
reunion whatever it is and all of a
sudden the guy that's built like me a
fat [ __ ] knows how much am I gonna enjoy
Rudi's show after that and every 20
minutes without smoking reefer the guy
goes in between every song the guy
coughs how long is it gonna take before
I look at the guy and go go [ __ ]
yourself and turn around and leave how
long is it gonna take you yep
you know right now we're experiencing I
remember growing up in the 80s the worst
thing you could catch me I'm talking
about the early 80s and 70s was like
gonorrhea the clap right by the end of
the decade it was aids the clap didn't
kill you unless you know let's say if
you never treated it can go to your
brain and kill you of course but aids
will definitely kill you especially back
in 88 89 right and now we're going
through the same thing you know people
used to say oh yeah it's the flu well
yeah people did die from the flu but
this thing it's it's at a whole
different level completely different
level
yeah the yoga come out of your dick it
was like softer I had a weird smell to
it but you didn't give a [ __ ] just wash
your dick off put on underwears and put
on some panty liners [ __ ] and you
know what saved me I went to a friend of
mine caught the clap same thing and he
had to go to a clinic and he asked me to
go with him and when we went there was a
guy sitting there with like a [ __ ]
man or a mancha scar on his mouth he
wants to suck somebody's dick and they
had her Bonner and he had like a thing
all around his mouth and right there I
learned I'm gonna keep my hands to
myself you know saying there's some bad
onions out there you can't be
everybody's [ __ ] monkey he'll expect
one of the greatest things about you
know being on tour with Ozzy is that he
liked to mentor mentor you you know he
meant to a Randy for a while and then I
guess when I joined the band I was like
the new the guy who had never been done
anything so let me mentor Rudy here
and one of these very first words of
wisdom was if if you want to be a rock
star you gotta catch every disease
that's out there like I totally you know
your community and I can't share it yeah
looks like you're healthier you're lobo
- you look really like you're a rock
star but you're i don't know i don't
know how you lived in LA
you're had the healthiest guy you have a
long marriage you're in your seventies
and your mama's still alive are you over
the best caramel of anyone I've ever met
you're an angel an angel on earth you
know I'm blessed and blessed but but I
gotta tell you the other the reason why
I'm still here in LA is because just
couple things first of all my wife was
born and raised here so it's very hard
for her to leave and when I arrived here
in the 70s I was reborn it was like I
have a connection with the city and it's
not the way that the city the structures
if there's there be there's this does a
frequency on on the in the city that
really resonated with me you know I've
been to certain places in the world and
there's frequencies like if you go to
Red Square Red Square in Moscow right
you're that big Red Square where they
did all the you know right in front of
the what is the styling grad or whatever
you know and the st. Peter's Basilica
there's a square and that's what they
had they had all of the may what is it
May Day May Day parades with the tanks
and the artillery and there's an energy
not necessarily a good energy but
definitely a very strong energy center
right there LA to me especially Laurel
Canyon going right into the city you
know into Hollywood this an incredible
energy that it doesn't make my body
vibrate any other place but here this is
why why I remain here
I don't know if it's if you guys know
anything I'm talking up you know for me
I've always said I feel that way about
the Comedy Store that there's like a
light that goes right from heaven to the
Comedy Store when you walk in there but
the rainbow has the same feeling the
rainbow yes yes certain places that you
belong there you know I think it's the
ghost that goes the energy on you yes
that goes there
you know it's so weird that I would move
here from here tomorrow if I could
you know I don't have anywhere to go I
don't know where to go we have ideas I
know that I probably I would miss it I
think that would miss a lot you know I
would have to go somewhere where again
the energy yeah I want more of a
community I live in the valley cuz I
like the community style of it but it's
really not a community it's just a bunch
of houses put together yeah I like that
I didn't I want to know the neighbor on
the corner I want to know the neighbor
on the other corner I want to know his
name I want him saying this I know the
neighbor next to me everybody else is
[ __ ] you know and I'm knocked on
doors introduce myself giving away free
masks it's not a community it's not
really a community and that's what these
can all this has come to me that I want
to go back to a community you know I was
watching do the right thing the other
night with Spike Lee and all those guys
Spike Lee play as a pizza delivery guy
in Brooklyn that does his deliveries on
foot so what does that tell you is that
the people that all the pizza from that
are from that community they're from how
far is the delivery to three blocks the
most eat when you watch that movie you
see where the sense of a community is we
have a liquor store we have this we
don't have that here there's no loyalty
here in businesses it's kind of weird
you know when this fall went down the
first thing I said was I'm gonna support
local business
I know at least all the business and I
know what it is to lose a business but I
found that the businesses weren't doing
it right you know if I walk into your
restaurant and the doors closed I ain't
walking in there you gotta get some
ventilation in that [ __ ] you got
six guys sweating over food with masks
on so you try you try but - yeah they go
back to what you were saying yeah I
don't they do the survey again about 10
days ago we're still at 6040 of people
feeling comfortable to go to outdoor
events like stadiums baseball games
concerts we're still at 6040 and even if
that goes 10% each way you still 50/50
or 70/30 which is still not good for our
field for we do people would they do the
survey and 50 people out of a hundred
said they would go they wouldn't go to a
game or concert right now so the state
of mind has even [ __ ] up lots on top
of that you don't maintain what the top
thing is Rudy it's not the Colvin it's
not the state of mind it's the social
consciousness people are in bad
positions right now people aren't loving
them all the love has been removed from
their heart and I'm not mad at them love
was removed from my heart when I was a
young man they've taken away your
livelihood they've taken away some of
your freedoms the check you supposed to
get to 1,200 you never got it in the
mail
guess what did you read the New York
Times article in the paper Sunday what's
going on in New York with the evictions
they're not [ __ ] around all that [ __ ]
they told you about waiving evictions
you don't have to pay the rent go to New
York and ask him what's going on New
York they gonna be homeless and nobody's
gonna stick up for them this was all
[ __ ] this was all [ __ ] I told
you that Lee said it that member Sartre
scarcetti whatever his name is man Scott
Kenny Los Angelenos you know your rents
will be waived
astly the first day of April they
known on this door with the [ __ ]
shelters in the area
his landlord put a [ __ ] note on his
door the renters do if not these are the
local shelters in the area
I thought [ __ ] he put at our rent
memorandum that if he didn't have to pay
rent I know 20 people that have told me
that's [ __ ] i know people had a live
move out of their apartments and move
into their places of business
because they had to make a choice so
right now people are having a hard time
like I said taxes are doing 10 and
unemployment wears out in 26 days wait
till we see how many people got shot
over the weekend from the fourth of July
the last night at 7:00 in New York 40
[ __ ] people got shot so be very
careful Rudy if somebody cut you off
telling me love them don't take offense
I'm not driving unless I go to Home
Depot yeah you and that [ __ ] Home
Depot I don't know what is he is my
buddy next door he's at Home Depot eight
times a day
he knocks on my door once a day Joe you
wouldn't have to have one of these
screws what makes you think I even got a
[ __ ] screw in my house I look like a
Johnny screwdriver Rudy I love you
what's the station when can they hear
you oh yeah my sister rock radio on the
dash Network and it's on various times
but definitely for sure 2 p.m. on
Fridays and this next week on Friday I
have Rick Nielson from cheap trick great
great conversation yeah oh yeah it's got
their own serious station oh yeah they
do last night I heard them do something
from live in Budokan yeah yeah he was
DJing it and then it would be played
again on Sunday at 4:00 p.m. but that's
like that the anchor date and time
sundays of 4 p.m. Pacific Daylight Time
or PST PBS DP whatever welcome I love
you hopefully I'll see you soon for some
popular
I ain't important to take care of
yourself give your wife a kiss have a
great week thank you dear
god bless bye bye alright you bad
[ __ ] I want to thank Rudy for
coming on man he's a good dude
70 years old been rockin for a long time
I gave him all the props in the world
another guy that inspires the [ __ ] out
of me when I talk to him cuz he's always
he's always doing something every time I
call his house what's going on I'm
planting a [ __ ] trees welcome Stan
house planting a tree he's always
[ __ ] those old-timers but not really
good [ __ ] man but listen again like I
was telling you the beginning of this
show the most important thing there this
quarantine is just trying to take care
yourself a little bit just do something
less add less salt to your food you know
walk an extra block do something I mean
I [ __ ] I'm losing my mind if it
wasn't for the podcast and me
communicate with you guys on Facebook
and on Twitter I'd be done right now I
swear to God nights for me a [ __ ]
harder than ever the first three months
it was like nothing lately it's been
harder than ever listen people like
won't go to San Diego and do a spot both
clubs are open here's the problem you
ever do a line of coke and then the guy
leaves you ever go some windows up it
gives you a great line of coke and then
he leaves and you're like what happened
to him and you're out like the [ __ ]
desert nobody's got coke now you're
sitting there and you're coming down
hard off a [ __ ] line that would have
killed the meal that's what happened to
me if I go do comedy right now I don't
just want to do comedy to do it and for
it to be over with La Jolla they're
doing great I think they had a good they
got it down to 60 people and the Marilyn
comedy club is on your people I can live
with that that's like 40% capacity
that's plenty of social
distancing and I'm not gonna do a long
show because this stuff you get covered
from sitting inside long periods of time
inside you know with no ventilation we
do those comedy clubs have [ __ ] I
insulted they're lucky you get [ __ ]
air in those things you know plan then
lucky if you get [ __ ] air in those
things so that's the only way I'm doing
it I mean there's a lot of things going
on my heart goes out to Brendan and
Brian I've checked them with both of
them Brian is feeling a little it it's
fluid conditions you know they're both
strong guys I know they both make it out
of this it's it's just a bump in the
road but we just got to be careful guys
we as the church listen we're all
savages I you know me I opposed [ __ ]
communism communism with my [ __ ]
heart I hate all that type of [ __ ] but
at this time right now we can just gotta
do a couple things and keep it simple
and those things are listen you see
eight people eights the magic number get
the [ __ ] out of that it's bad number
right now tomorrow's today's the eighth
bad number eight to ten people that's
how it starts you know that's how it
starts indoors
you know don't listen to me I don't give
a [ __ ] what you do I'm just trying to
tell you that I care about you guys and
there's just a couple of things you know
washing your hands take two showers you
know I'm saying I'd rather you be over
cautious than you know we don't know
what we're dealing with do you think I
believe this is a virus Walt
nobody gets the flu in the summer so do
I believe I don't believe nothing all I
know is that you gotta avoid people you
got a [ __ ] wash your hands you gotta
wear a mask you know and you know what
man you see a lot of people I know you
half of us are losing our minds you want
me to lie to you and tell you that this
fourth of July was the best fourth of
July I've had in my life
is that what you really want me to tie
you know it suck dick it's something you
know because we didn't have the freedom
to go to the beach like we usually do
we didn't have it I didn't complain I
didn't force it I didn't push the hand I
understand that I have a family what if
my wife contracts this [ __ ] thing and
something happens to her you think I'm
qualified to [ __ ] raise a
seven-year-old by myself are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] guys are you [ __ ] [ __ ] I
mean I could do a couple things okay but
I can't raise no seven-year-old by
myself and I wouldn't want my wife to be
stuck with a burden nothing nobody's
gonna die but we're not young people no
more you guys are young you guys have
the opportunity to set an example man
put the [ __ ] mask on it
who gives a [ __ ] what a [ __ ] mask on
that says suck my dick I don't give a
[ __ ] I wouldn't be mad at you I'm
insulted too you know how hard it is to
walk walking two blocks for the mascot
do you know how hard it is to ride a
bike past 20 minutes with a [ __ ] mask
on you start getting dizzy and snots
come on Ian knows this [ __ ] I gotta
throw those masks away every time I go
for a bike ride I had to cut down on my
bike rides well I'm just going to say
you guys have heard me get bronchitis
over the years if you think breathing in
a mask is hard try breathing with
bronchitis and I've heard bright this is
what it works or it trust me but you
know you'll be begging from ask if you
get this that's just what I heard yeah
so please take care of yourselves
drink water vitamin D is big demand you
know be a good friend to yourself like
the guy told Tony Soprano be that
doesn't those words have resonated with
me for a long time be a good friend to
yourself it's it's it's so real you know
listen guys this [ __ ] I want to do all
the [ __ ] time you don't have to [ __ ]
this number three no no I've not broken
down you look at me do I look like a
[ __ ] that misses a beam a bean
and cheese burrito with [ __ ]
guacamole in there and some [ __ ]
sauce on top of it that's my world guys
that's my [ __ ] cheat day that's my
Sunday when I [ __ ] got 44 points left
over I go to [ __ ] down there and I
get it during the week I get the vegan
salad I haven't been in there I just
because you scared me everybody
was like you know every time I go by
there's only three people but it's just
something about it they they trapped it
in now I like it when it's open you know
I don't so I'm like you guys I'm not
scared of anything but I do respect
things there's things you gotta respect
whether you want or that respect this if
not for yourself for your uncle [ __ ]
Joey okay for all people like me that
we've been smoking dope for 27 years you
[ __ ]
come along now and [ __ ] get weed in a
weeds flowers I was smoking weed when
you had to go into the jungle to get a
[ __ ] bag of dope you know I'm saying
when you had to go deep deep deep into
the [ __ ] murky waters of the
underworld
now we're getting dope everywhere it's
like it's like being gay now it ain't no
big deal I wish you would have seen gays
in the 70s had to walk around with capes
in a backpack you know nobody could see
him that's because the guys that I hung
out with Martin the [ __ ] they took the
beatings so these gay guys could jump up
and down today and have parades and go
tough you see him on Fire Island jumping
up and down out they had a party father
90 gay guys jumping up and down it was
just instant [ __ ] vindictive you know
I don't wish nothing bad on nobody but
you can't put 90 guys together if you
think what came out of womb and it's
dangerous
wait do you see what comes out of
[ __ ] Fire Island and [ __ ] by the end
of the summer I love you [ __ ]
listen the most important thing about
this time is if you don't have a sense
of humor about yourself if you're not
gonna laugh about yourself kill yourself
because it's not gonna work out for you
trust me when I'm telling you you gotta
find the humor in things right now I'm
talking about as you're getting evicted
and you can't you're putting your
[ __ ] lawn chair in the [ __ ]
station wagon you gotta look at the land
long ago we did a good run and I'm
saying go to the bathroom look at the
piece of [ __ ] I left in there [ __ ]
I painted the walls but go see the dead
stick I left you in there if you don't
have a sense of humor about yourself
you're not gonna make it through in
these trying times learn to laugh at
yourself I laugh at myself all [ __ ]
day one last story okay my daughter goes
on this program
call like you ginger I don't know what
the [ __ ] of this guy really it teaches
you how to speak Spanish good thing
about this I don't think so guys you
don't understand so about two three
years ago I go on the road and show with
you all Romero guys I got blasted by
Spanish people
blasted I mean just tormented about my
Spanish that my Spanish is horrific
a lot of speak Spanish which I don't
number one I speak Cuban Spanish okay
when I was in high school for one week I
took Spanish and I was like I'm not
doing this this is too confusing
I'm Spanish I don't get this [ __ ] I'm
not doing it so I switched to Italian at
mr. Parmesan oh he had one eye higher
than the other one hilarious bad skin we
used to torment them he used to say
buongiorno send your profits on and we
tell him go [ __ ] yourself
teacher wait who said that he was kind
of crazy was it same food every day
anyway somebody thought it comes to me
my wife says you know Mercy's learning
Spanish on her own she wants to surprise
you so I don't know [ __ ] so one night
she's like that look I'm playing little
Inga whatever the [ __ ] the name of the
game is and do you want to help me and I
go yeah so she's up to like level 18 on
her own she's climbed up all these
[ __ ] barriers on their own because
they give him like points elections or
whatever the [ __ ] I'm saying so she's
got enough to like level 16 or level 18
I don't [ __ ] know so she sits next to
me I tend the TV off she asked my three
or four questions anyway to be honest to
you she asked me to play three questions
and I went over three and she went down
for like level oven and she got up and
she was so pissed at me she's like how
can you be Spanish and gets three
questions wrong bad that doesn't make
sense dad down level 11
she just marched the [ __ ] room
furious some a mother astor yesterday
you have a problem with ego actually
daddy's like what are you [ __ ] nuts
last time I asked that lose of the
Spanish questions I went oh in three I'm
never gonna ask him about Spanish dad
doesn't talk that type of Spanish so
that's my [ __ ] up for a week
I made my daughter go down like four
levels in Spanish because I don't know
they're between como or something else I
don't [ __ ] know I know a couple words
I know how to get by and I know how to
save my ass I know how to make you laugh
I know how to make me laugh in Spanish
and that's the only thing that matters
so for the next couple days listen I
know it's a trying time taxes are done
unemployment's done in two or three
weeks you don't have you don't need to
have anything to have a sense of humor
please keep your centium because at the
end of the day that's all you have it's
more than money what good is having
money if you don't [ __ ] laugh you
know what I laugh at myself every day
cuz I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I did enjoy
that my sense of humor is tremendous
because I laugh at myself so please take
it easy don't shoot nobody don't get
shot cuz this shooting season out there
forty-four people that shot in New York
70 in Chicago what are they giving out
[ __ ] guns on Chicago what are they
doing in these [ __ ] cities I love
Chicago I taped my special in your city
I did the theater I love that [ __ ]
city with all my heart what are you
doing out there you guys took cops and
robbers to a different level just
shooting at each other now but anyway
all no jokes I wanna say a prayer for
the country and say a prayer for the
church family and also for my man serge
ortega who's going through a hard time
like i said if you're not his friend on
facebook friend them sending a message
strong from church love and that's it
and that's that me and we will be back
one night this weekend to do a [ __ ]
instagram live to rock your [ __ ]
world maybe i'll talk me into light
himself on fire or something since we're
on a hannibal sabbatical this week we
had some problems i had some problems so
we said [ __ ] it we might as well go back
to being normal again I want to thank
Rudy I want to thank you [ __ ]
don't forget Rudy show he's I forget he
mentioned it on there when it's on and
it's not listen that's a true musician
with
true chops and I'm proud to call my
brother and father the church family so
I want to thank Rudy I want to thank you
guys again my heart to the Ortegas and
Sergio get the rollerskating [ __ ]
I heard rollerskating with four toes is
better than rollerskating with five
sometimes anyway I love you guys thank
you for listening to the church dates
I'm doing Brea it just depends when the
[ __ ] they're opening it I'll keep you
guys updated take this meal we have a
great week I'll see you guys will either
night on Instagram live do it
[ __ ]
[Music]